ja ich habe die impfpflicht debatte mit
großer faszination verfolgt und etwas
festgestellt was mich eigentlich
überrascht hat die politik immer wieder
in die gleiche falle und macht immer
wieder den gleichen fehler sie will
nämlich am besten alles für alle und am
besten für immer regeln und dabei wäre
es aber viel besser punktuell vorzugehen
und sich ein konkretes problem ehrlich
vor augen zu führen und es dann konkret
zu lösen was meine ich damit wenn wir
uns zurück erinnern als die ersten
wellen gebrochen werden mussten wie es
damals hieß von kona da gab es lockt
downs und ausgangssperren und
restaurants waren lahmgelegt und
geschäfte und vereine und schulen und
kindergärten dabei hätte es genügt die
altenheime zu schützen und damit konkret
leben zu retten als es dann bei allen
schon klar war dass draußen an der
frischen luft nichts passieren kann man
sich eigentlich nicht ansteckt gab es in
vielen städten in allen teilen
deutschlands plötzlich masken pflicht
beim joggen beim spazierengehen leute
wurden beim spazierengehen an getrötet
holt sie abstand obwohl längst klar was
da passiert und jetzt also da hätte man
sich viel lieber auf die sprayer
hotspots richtig konzentrieren sollen
aber nein man hat die menschen beim
spaziergehen belassen und jetzt jetzt
also die allgemeine impfpflicht für alle
ab 18 ist einer der anträge um die es
geht um meine frage lautet wer sich viel
besser zu sagen wer sind eigentlich
diejenigen die am ende des
gesundheitssystem belasten werden wenn
sie sich nicht impfen lassen denn in den
krankenhäusern und auf den
intensivstationen kommen menschen über
60 an die vorerkrankungen haben und
ungeimpft sind das ist die zielgruppe um
es einmal deutlich zu sagen und ich
frage mich warum die politik nicht alles
auf wert um diese zielgruppe nur diese
zielgruppe dazu zu bringen sich impfen
zu lassen mit konzentrierten
werbeaktionen von mir aus sagt man
rentnern eine monatsrente zurück gegen
info man macht also in fremde mann macht
persönliche gespräche der bundeskanzler
schreibt persönlich alle über 60
jährigen an er ruft sie per video an und
macht sie selber darauf aufmerksam was
seine verantwortung sie haben das alles
geschieht aber nicht stattdessen werden
kann gesunde 22-jährige verdammt sich
mit der spritze da irgendwie in
impfstoffen am rand das geht mir nicht
ein also doch lieber konkret vor allem
ein punktuell vor allem müssen sozusagen
darunter leiden oder sind davon
betroffen ein problem klar benennen und
es klar lösen hilft mehr als alle zu
belästigt
klar sie kann ihr da nur zustimmen und
auch wenn ich schon vermutet dass frau
war nicht vielleicht auch zustimmt
können wir einmal fragen wie sehen wie
das frau wagenknecht
also werben natürlich vor allem bei den
älteren das finde ich richtig weil da
ist die gefahr groß aber ich finde auch
bei den älteren das ist jetzt ja auch
nicht anders gesagt worden aber ich will
es noch mal ausdrücklich sagen also ich
bin auch gegen eine pflicht ab 60 oder
ab 50 oder wann auch immer weil auch
ältere menschen das volle recht haben
sich über ihren körper selber zu
entscheiden und ich wollte auch wirklich
einmal noch die zahlen nennen weil das
immer wieder so gesagt wird so pauschal
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
ich meine wir hatten im letzten herbst
auf der bei der del tabelle in der
spitze
4800 koma patienten auf den
intensivstationen
wir haben aber alleine im letzten jahr
wegen des pflegenotstands über 5000
intensivbetten abgebaut das heißt wenn
die politik wenigstens dafür gesorgt
hätte dass die kapazitäten konstant
bleiben also da nicht mal ausbauen
müssen aber wenigstens konstant bleiben
dann hätte wären die koma patientin gar
nicht ins gewicht gefallen und ich finde
man immer wieder sagt also die menschen
sollen sich so was verpflichten müsste
auch die künftig mal ihre hausaufgaben
machen und deswegen also verpflichtung
für älteren einwerben bei älteren jahr
das halte ich für richtig auch
aufklärung alles richtig aber ich finde
auch die impflücken bei den älteren wenn
wir die zahlen sehen die es da gibt und
die realistischen zahlen also man muss
ja sagen das lka wir sind ja in einem
daten blindflug wir wissen ja auch noch
nicht mal die genaue impfquote in
deutschland aber das lka sagt immer ist
die reale ist 5 prozentpunkte höher als
die ausgewiesene weil viele impfungen
nicht gemeldet wurden dann heißt das sie
sind bei den über 60 jährigen
real bei einer impfquote von 93 prozent
vor und ich muss sagen also die sieben
prozent das muss unser gesundheitssystem
im notfall verkraften und ein teil davon
ist wahrscheinlich sogar schon gelesen
pro wagen nicht viele menschen haben die
debatte auch heute verfolgt eben um die
impfpflicht darum was die politik jetzt
macht aus ihrer sicht glauben sie dass
am ende eine impfpflicht kommen wird
oder werden da bei der spd bei den
grünen bei der fdp auch diejenigen
überwiegen die sagen moment mal omikron
das ist doch nicht mehr so gefährlich
und was wissen wir was dagegen nächste
will hilft
[Musik]
der politische diskurs hat sich mehr und
mehr von denen von dieser realen basis
abgekoppelt jetzt geht es eigentlich
darum scholz hat angekündigt als kanzler
er will die impfpflicht die cdu rückt
ihn jetzt und sagt ja zeigt auch mal das
so führungsstärke hast so ungefähr und
die ampel oder zumindest die spd die fdp
steht aber zumindest die spd versteht
das jetzt irgendwie als ein
führungsversagen wenn sie davon abgehen
und das ist eine gefährliche dynamik
weil das eben bedeutet dass man nicht so
sehr offen für argumente oder
entwicklungen ist sondern jetzt in
dieser politischen eigenlogik meint man
muss jetzt beweisen dass man das
durchsetzen kann und ich hoffe wirklich
dass man irgendwann merkt das ist ein
denkbar ungeeignetes thema um jetzt
führungsstärke zu diskutieren also bei
solchen gravierenden entscheidungen muss
es wirklich um das medizinisch
notwendige gehen deswegen es ist
vielleicht noch offen aber so richtig
ich würde zumindest noch nicht sagen
dass es begraben ist also sehr schon
einige die das unbedingt wollen sehr
spannende analyse vom wagen des tableaus
wieviel rechthaberei ist da auch bei
ihnen in der partei sie haben sich doch
mal festgelegt und gesagt mensch wir
wollen die impfpflicht wir sind ja das
team vorsicht auch bei der leute die da
muss ich widersprechen wie vielleicht
kabarett ist dabei
die sonst keine rechthaberei das mag den
anderen fraktionen einmal die man aber
aber wir haben uns tatsächlich ja bisher
nicht festgelegt sondern wir haben eine
sache klar formuliert und das will ich
hier auch nochmal betonen wir haben eine
bundesregierung die gerade bei solch
wichtigen fragen eigentlich initiativen
in den bundestag einbringen muss die
auch einen administrativen apparat die
ministerien hat die
behördenmitarbeiter hat die auch die
entsprechenden gesetze ausarbeiten
müssen und die natürlich auch viele
fragen beantworten können mit fachlicher
expertise über die wir hier in der runde
auch gesprochen haben und dass all das
die bundesregierung bisher nicht gemacht
dass sein verein halten verlosen heute
in wahrheit bei dem wären meine bundes
lage hier die rede der name klingt ja
ganz interessant was verband nicht
gesagt weil er uns aber der vorwurf ist
ja hier bin ich habe ja schon was ist
eigentlich habe ich ja gar keine
position festgelegt als cdu und csu
deswegen kann man uns diesen vorwürfen
machen zb gegen die genau deswegen bei
uns wird das ja auch kontrovers ist aber
trotzdem spannender punkt ist darf nicht
sein was nicht sein darf gerade oder
genau also ich habe heute auch
herren stehen noch mal gefragt ob er
eigentlich sozusagen es wagen könnte
jetzt wo sein kanzler und sein
gesundheitsminister sagen mensch leute
gemeint die impfpflicht sorgt durch
stege aus dem norden ich bin anderer
meinung da hat er natürlich gesagt ich
da stehen das sage immer meine meinung
aber natürlich ist nichts zu spüren dass
das von olaf scholz wie ich finde in der
geste eines großen demokraten ins
parlament verwiesene thema verbunden mit
ein abgeordneter ist nur seinem gewissen
und nicht der fraktion verantwortlich so
soll die abstimmung sein mandat sich
jetzt schon wieder zurecht in es ist
trotzdem dann am ende schwierig
schwierig schwierig werden in der npd
ist und anders abstimmt als der
lauterbach unterstützt und es werden
viele nicht machen zumal man dann
übrigens abstimmt wie die böse afd das
ist ja quasi mit einer politischen
todesstrafe das bestraft wenn rauskommt
dass du abgestimmt hast wie die afd man
durfte ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
sagen ich finde auch dass im osten die
sonne aufgeht wenn die afg festgestellt
haben ist im osten die sonne aufgeht
also ich sehe hier schon wirkungskreis
die dazu führen können dass abgeordnete
die eigentlich gegen die impfpflicht
während halt dann sagen komm mama die
jetzt halt und das ist bei dieser
wichtigen frage einer der wenigen fragen
die an dem körper von jedem einzelnen
menschen rennen nicht nur an sein
intellekt an sanft an seine gespräche
richtig hand anlegt an den körper zu
leichtfertig